welcome back time to take your toys to
tobin auto group the sponsors of this
next segment here's rocky with an update
on our great toy drive
we are checking in on the great toy
drive between of course channel 8 and
the tobin auto group am i heard that we
are currently in the og
tobin dealership we are in the og store
uh we we've been open since 1998 and
chav has just created like one of the
greatest dealerships in the valley so
i'm i'm happy to be a part of it earlier
you or last week i think you asked me
about my favorite toy growing up yeah
hey this is my favorite toy as an adult
behind us yeah and you are not alone
yeah everybody loves a good dodge so
let's talk about what we're doing for
the kids in the community guys do enough
for the adults yeah for sure
um so what we're doing for the kids is
we're just gathering as many toys as
possible for shae tree which is again an
organization that helps battered kids
and battered uh women so we are so
excited to be a part of this and so
grateful to to contribute in such a big
way to the community absolutely and what
can people bring in
new toys any unopened toys okay
you can bring balls dolls uh mrs potato
head we got mr potato head
boys skateboards all that perfect and
how long this is going to december 15th
and you guys have boxes at each of the
dealerships here in the valley
automotive yep we have boxes at tobin
dodge which we're currently in the od
store like you said uh we got to make a
sign that says og yes
we have one being made right now really
no but uh also toby kia you guys could
stop by the tobin kia store or you guys
can stop by the all-new tobin offer
romeo dealership uh in the valley auto
mall now so perfect now in true tobin
fashion
once you buy a car
or
through the 15th donate a toy you get to
hit the big gong yeah you gotta hit it
loud okay okay yeah we got to try it out
let's go let's go
let's do this all right this is this is
what you do this is the turbine is it
this is the the og way
do you guys say anything before
all available sales all available sales
uh we'd like to congratulate rocky on
donating a bunch of toys thank you so
much for your contribution awesome and
thank and we like to congratulate the
shae tree who is benefiting from yes so
here we go
oh my god
okay
that is fun wow
don't mind me everybody i just donated
some toys that's right
our great toy drive continues through
wednesday with the help of tobin auto
group and telus international you can
drop off a new unwrapped toy or even a
gift card at any of the dealerships on
your screen the donations will benefit
the shade tree organization